[Música]
el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva aseguró que la policía de
los militares colaboraron con los
fanáticos del ex mandatario Jair
bolsonaro en el ataque a las sedes de
los tres poderes el domingo pasado esto
al tiempo que la policía federal halló
el borrador de un decreto que habría
permitido que Jair bolsonaro
interviniera los resultados de las
elecciones
El Congreso de Perú aprobó la creación
de una comisión especial para investigar
la posible responsabilidad estatal en el
cerca de medio centenar de muertes que
dejan hasta ahora las manifestaciones
ciudadanas principalmente en el sur del
país la comisión tendrá 90 días para
esclarecer los hechos
en su presentación de memoria y cuenta
ante el congreso venezolano el informe
de su gestión de 2022 Nicolás maduro
pidió a Estados Unidos La retirada de
las sanciones económicas y destacó que
pese a ella es la economía venezolana
creció ampliamos desde Caracas
Bienvenidos a Nueva informativo de
france24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Brasil en donde hay controversia tras
una recientes declaraciones del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien afirmó que policías y militares
fueron Cómplices de la multitud de
Seguidores del expresidente Jair
bolsonaro que saquearon edificios
públicos en Brasilia el mandatario
señaló que la policía no impidió las
manifestaciones y desmanes veamos el
informe de amal benotman
en Brasil en medio de la conmoción tras
el violento ataque del congreso del
palacio presidencial de plan alto y del
tribunal Federal por Seguidores del
expresidente Jair bolsonaro que no
reconocen la victoria de Lula todo el
mundo se pregunta cómo pudieron unos
pocos miles de personas desarmadas
invadier tan fácilmente los lugares más
importantes y mejor guardados de la
democracia en el país y cómo pudieron
permanecer dentro de estos edificios
durante varias horas sin ser detenidos
para el presidente Lula da Silva la
implicación de la policía y los
militares no está en duda
es importante decir que hubo muchos
Cómplices entre la Policía Militar hubo
muchas personas de las fuerzas armadas
que fueron Cómplices estoy convencido de
que la puerta del palacio se abrió para
permitir la entrada de estas personas
porque no vi que la puerta estuviera
rota es decir significa que alguien
facilitó su entrada vamos a investigar a
ver qué ha pasado
la responsabilidad de los hechos podría
ser difícil de establecer ya que la
estructura policial brasileña es
compleja la policía federal recibe
órdenes del gobierno nacional mientras
que la Policía Militar encargada de
mantener el orden público está bajo el
mando de los gobernadores de los 27
estados de la Federación es esta última
y en particular la Policía Militar del
Distrito Federal de Brasilia la que está
ahora en el centro de las críticas está
entidad conocía los riesgos de una
invasión pocas horas antes del asalto
mientras miles de bolsonaristas
convergían hacia la capital la agencia
Nacional de inteligencia le había
transmitido boletines de alerta
El Congreso de Perú aprobó la creación
de una comisión que investigará las
muertes de manifestantes a las protestas
que desde hace varias semanas tienen
lugar en el país la comisión tendrá 90
días para esclarecer los hechos entre
tanto ascienden a 49 los fallecidos por
las recientes marchas en el sur del país
particularmente en puno juliaca Y cusco
en donde fue suspendida la operación del
Aeropuerto Internacional
alrededor de medio centenar de muertos
en las mayores protestas en décadas en
Perú y por imágenes como estas la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos está en una gira de tres días en
el país después de semanas con la vista
puesta en la crisis social la comisión
fue recoger testimonios de víctimas en
juliaca donde el lunes murieron 18
personas en la jornada más Sangrienta de
las protestas pero también fueron hasta
Arequipa ica y Lima en la capital la
presidenta Dina boluarte recibió a
estuardo ralón primer vicepresidente de
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos y al comisionado Joel Hernández
que encabezan la delegación contra la
presidenta Hay un gran malestar social
por la gestión de la crisis y las
acusaciones de violación de derechos
humanos de la policía luego de
un intento de golpe de estado del
expresidente Pedro Castillo no pensé que
iba a haber tremenda violencia a nivel
nacional
teníamos que tomar medidas necesarias
para salvaguardar la vida y la
tranquilidad de los 33 millones de
peruanos y peruanos la comisión dará una
conferencia de prensa el viernes para
compartir sus conclusiones siguiendo su
mandato de garantizar la defensa de los
Derechos Humanos la cidh Es un órgano
principal de autónomo de la organización
de los Estados Americanos Aunque su
mandato surge de este organismo
precisamente una misión de alto nivel de
la oea ya había visitado Perú entre el
20 y 23 de noviembre en la que recomendó
una tregua política y diálogo esta había
visitado Perú a petición del derrocado
presidente Pedro Castillo en prisión
preventiva desde el 7 de diciembre tras
disolver el congreso que iba a reunirse
para votar su destitución en medio de
señalamientos de corrupción
desde su encarcelación manifestantes y
partidarios de Castillo han estado
exigiendo la renuncia de boluarte el
cierre del Congreso el adelanto de
elecciones a 2023 y una asamblea
Constituyente
en Venezuela tuvo lugar la presentación
de memoria y cuenta del presidente
Nicolás Maduro ante el congreso es decir
el informe de su gestión del año 2022 en
el pidió el gobierno de Estados Unidos
La retirada de las sanciones que afirmó
redujeron en un 99% los ingresos por el
petróleo pese a ello maduro destacó el
crecimiento de la economía nuestra
corresponsal en Caracas Daniela Zambrano
no se ampliaba anteriormente
durante su presentación de memor y
cuenta ante el parlamento Nicolás Maduro
pidió una vez más a Joe biden levantar
todas las sanciones que pesan contra
Venezuela las calificó de criminales
dijo que eran más de 927 que el 42%
afectaba organismos gubernamentales el
18% de la industria petrolera y el 17% a
la economía y finanzas del país
impidiendo lo demás acceder a unos
veinte mil millones de dólares en el
exterior y al oro depositado en los
bancos de Inglaterra calificó además de
ridículo y risible el reciente apoyo que
ofreció el gobierno británico al
parlamento venezolano electo en el año
2015 de mayoría opositora por desconocer
las últimas elecciones legislativas
maduro dijo además que las sanciones
provocaron la caída del 99% de los
ingresos petroleros en Venezuela pero
que sin embargo el producto interno
bruto tuvo un crecimiento del quince por
ciento destacó además la reducción del
índice de desempleo punto nueve a siete
punto ocho por ciento sin embargo no dio
cifras sobre pobreza maduro ordenó al
gabinete presentar en las próximas
semanas un proyecto de ley para
facilitar la exportaciones en el país
una presentación de memoria y cuenta que
tuvo un inmediatas críticas por parte de
la oposición venezolana que destacó lo
que no se habló Durante este discurso de
maduro y es precisamente el tema de la
migración venezolana siete punto cinco
millones de migrantes refugiados 53% de
pobreza extrema 274 presos políticos y
un salario mínimo de menos de siete
dólares denunciaba Juan guaidó a través
de las redes sociales en Estados Unidos
El fiscal general designó un fiscal
independiente para investigar los
documentos clasificados hallados en la
casa de Joe biden previo al que fuera
presidente la Casa Blanca afirma que el
presidente no sabe Qué contienen los
papeles pero reitero que colaborará con
la investigación
es un caso que podría desestabilizar sus
aspiraciones de reelección en 2024 el
segundo bloque de documentos
clasificados encontrados en su
residencia por su propio equipo de
abogados deja a Joe biden en el centro
de las miradas y será puesto bajo
investigación por decisión Del fiscal
general de Estados Unidos merry Garland
hoy estoy aquí para anunciar el
nombramiento de Robert Heart como
abogado especial en conformidad con las
normas del departamento de Justicia que
rigen estos asuntos de conformidad con
esas normas hoy he notificado a los
miembros designados de cada cámara del
Congreso de la cita
en una escueta comparecencia el
mandatario estadounidense afirmó que
cooperarán Y aunque no hay precisiones
sobre la cantidad de documentos dijo que
es pequeña
estamos cooperando total y completamente
con la revisión del departamento de
Justicia como parte de este proceso mis
abogados revisaron otros lugares donde
se almacenaron documentos de mi tiempo
como vicepresidente y terminaron la
revisión anoche descubrieron una pequeña
cantidad de documentos clasificados de
marcas y áreas de almacenamiento en
archivadores en mi casa y en mi
biblioteca personal
esto dio lugar a las críticas de los
republicanos quienes comparan la
situación de biden con la de Donald
Trump sin embargo hay profundas
diferencias entre un caso y el otro
al momento sólo son 10 los documentos
que estaban en posesión de biden
mientras que Trump albergó 325 en su
casa de Florida además el expresidente
se resistió a entregarlos a la justicia
algo que no sucedió con el demócrata y
en el caso de biden los papeles hallados
no coinciden con su periodo como
presidente
hasta aquí las noticias se iban
conectados
[Música]